season five of my academia will be
animating a lot of great new characters
and quirks for the first time ever
so today i thought i'd do a quick
explainer video on one of the villains
that we'll be seeing
so the character for today's video is
getting and he actually made his debut
in the manga almost one year ago today
and since that first appearance there's
been a ton of fan speculation about him
with the most prominent theory being
that he is actually toyotaroki
and not darby i personally feel
confident in saying there's a 0.00001
chance of that actually happening but i
felt i shouldn't mention the idea
because it is the most prominent theory
about getting
and you know like i said there is the
tiny chance that horukoshi could troll
us and actually do something like that
but with that said
this video will not contain any plot
spoilers for season five but it will
explain his quirk and his philosophy
and i'm briefly going to touch on how i
think he would compare in a fight
against shoto
so do be sure to subscribe and let's get
into it starting with this quirk
it actually doesn't have an official
name yet so for the time being we'll
just call it ice bending
now contrary to what you might expect
this quirk does not allow him to
generate ice from his body
like it does for shoto but instead it
allows getting to freely control all
eyes within a certain range
now the range of the ice that he can
manipulate is pretty wide from this
panel in the manga we can see it covers
at least an entire neighborhood worth of
buildings
and given how much he's trained i would
estimate he can go much further than
that
with this power getting can warp the ice
into structures that support him in
battle
for example he can make a giant pair of
ice hands which he can then manipulate
as if they were his own hands or as we
see in this panel
he can seemingly shoot ice into the
ground which then propels him into the
air
other examples include shaping ice into
these shards which he uses to
one shot multiple people at the same
time and who could forget this slab
of ice which he uses to fly around like
the silver surfer
using a special strategy getting is
actually able to generate more ice if
the environment allows it
this quirk allows him to control the
temperature of any ice so that means
that he can send ice into a nearby
supply of water
whether that be a lake or maybe some
underground pipes and then by lowering
the temperature of the ice significantly
enough
the water around it then completely
becomes frozen as well and then he's
able to control that because it's now
ice
in the manga we see that his quirk is so
strong that once activated the ice just
comes flying straight towards him no
matter what's in the way
in this grocery store the ice literally
broke through the glass it was that
powerful
as a side note getting doesn't seem to
have any support items from what we've
seen he just you know wears this jacket
and this was surprising to me because
he's a character very much reliant on
his environment and you know how much
ice is nearby
so it would be really useful if you
could you know maybe carry around a few
cubes of ice in like a
tiny portable freezer that can fit in
your pocket just a suggestion but i
think something like that
would be really useful for him now
moving on to getting's philosophy
i'm sure some of you noticed in season
four but we briefly saw a glimpse of
this book which is titled the meta
liberation war
this book was written by a criminal
known as destro who is someone that we
saw earlier in the season during one of
gentle criminals flashbacks
destro believed that everyone in society
should have the ability
to freely use their quirks getting
himself is a firm believer in these
ideals
and he takes it a step further and
envisions a world in which people's
societal status is purely based
on the power of their quirk and the
group that getand has aligned himself
with in the series
also believe the same thing due to this
belief he's honed his quirk literally
his entire life and never actually
attended school
because he was too busy trying to master
this ability what this means is that
getting has trained longer with this
quirk
than most professional heroes which is
pretty crazy when you think about it
as a consequence of that getting has
amazing technique and also has a very
good perception of his opponent's
weaknesses and we'll be seeing that in
season 5.
however when we look at the ultra
analysis book his stats are not as great
as you would imagine with his technique
being rated a 4 out of 6
which for a guy who's practiced his
entire life is not really that great
i mean deku has a 5 out of 6 and he's
only had his quirk for like one year
but i will say in my personal opinion i
feel like the ultra analysis book
while it is a good reference point many
of the ratings are just absurd and don't
make too much sense
regardless of that we've had our fair
share of elemental quirks in this series
and i gotta say ice bending is
definitely one of the best it would have
been
seriously overpowered if he could
generate ice from his body but given
that getting isn't really meant to be a
boss villain
i think horikoshi did the right thing in
giving it the limitations that it has
bearing all that in mind how would he
compare in a battle against someone like
todoroki
i think it's pretty obvious that getting
completely nullifies the eyesight of
shoto's body
as any attack he could attempt to make
would automatically be turned against
him
from the perspective of shoto being
limited to justice fireside wouldn't be
too bad
as he'd still have the elemental
advantage as uh fire definitely uh beats
ice in a one-to-one match-up
that said getting isn't really the type
to be intimidated by
unfavorable matchup as he possesses an
unshakable faith in his abilities and
that's why i reckon if they fought each
other one versus one
as they are right now at least as long
as shoto doesn't know about the ice
bending ability in advance
i reckon that he'd use it and then get
him would catch him by surprise
and take him out before he had a chance
to rethink his strategy like i said
we'll be seeing him do his thing in
season five during the maybelline
academia arc
and i personally believe that when it
comes to his big fight that happened in
the manga
i think in that anime it will be
extended and drawn out a bit more
that's just my personal hope but i do
actually think it will happen
thanks for watching and i do have a
video coming tomorrow so be sure to
subscribe and turn on notifications
peace out